we just have a look what is he doing in
the very person from the question itself
to his first line of work you've read
three and five camps - seven and six
attempts someone hand up what has he
done yet - large okay so he see look see
these gay teens over two and five is not
gonna talk to each other in their
present fault so he's converted the
denominators by multiplying in this case
by 5 over 5
what's he multiply this time over here
at 2 over 2 right do you agree with
these conversions has it converted
correctly yeah so far so good before we
move on is there anything else you could
have done apart from that I think it's
wrong but did anyone do something
different rent what do you mean might
take away with front numbers ok so you
could have done 3 take away 7 which
would give you negative 4 and then
you're like well I've dealt with the
whole numbers now
now I'll deal with the fraction is there
anyone who did something different again
own I just made ontological yeah ok so
maybe you wrote did you write 7 over 2
all right
yes yes - what would this be 38 on 5 ok
so if you have a look at these two
approaches both of them are fine it's
their issue with either of them but I
just want to point out you can do this
both ways in fact if you have a look at
this line can you see you're going to
then do what I rig did the first time
right get a comment to domineer do you
see 7 over 2 is the same as those you
might over 10 do you really no do you
see they've just done the steps at a
slightly different order but you arrive
at the same spot so long as your numbers
of like ok right finally you've gone 35
paper weighs 76 equals negative 41 on 10
what do you think you're happy with that
yeah if you had converted it to a
nuclear all right I guess that would be
minus 4 what was it - 4 negative 4 ends
one on 10 either would you find the
question did not ask you to put it in
one form or not
so I devotion get a secret job okay yeah
metallic here's a rationalize
denominator 8 root 2 & 3 can I get a
show here to agrees yes fantastic thank
you move now now this is great however
would point out you notice how Brandon
had to do a little bit of extra legwork
to get there particularly this number is
very large now it's not wrong it's just
a bit of a longer can someone tell me
what was it that maybe you could have
done differently to make it a little bit
simpler errors instead of three times
three over three yeah yeah okay so see
this sky here and this night here
they're not wrong got on the top and
bottom so everything we find will be
accurate but it's not necessary right if
we're trying to rationalize then the
issue is the irrational part they're
there it's just the root to just amicus
so this is what I look like a rich
children tree if you did that directly
this would become 16 root 2 on 6 and
then you still get the same answer again
but you just deal with smaller numbers
which is kind of myself and plus my
brainless ok right now number three this
is weird because usually you have to do
this in Reverse don't you you get given
in the equation and then I asked you to
work on it and work on it until you get
this as your last one so I've asked you
to kind of do it in reverse and then you
will got antiquated just one you want to
shower them yeah go ahead
oh yeah - 103 and plus fiber rate yep
equals P R equals to minus 106 over 8
minus 1 is minus 1 um yeah 6 and then
it's a mixing room again 96 every yeah
ok yeah I think it works out too ok so
if you have a look you have a look
what's what's usually actually done it's
a straight line
I know if you look at this specially
like I don't even know where to begin
point which by the way makes it the best
kind of question because those questions
where you're like oh I know exactly what
to do here you're stuck on autopilot
you're almost not really thinking you're
just kind of doing what your calculator
does whereas here when you're like oh
I'm not sure what direction to go you
that means you have to actually apply
some thought is a straight line to go
from this line to this line to notice if
I maybe write it backwards like this
what's the one operation that gets us
from this line to that one so I do what
have I done to both sides of the
equation
wait hold on sorry so I'm comparing this
line here the one I handed to you with
this one which is cushy but she's I just
rearranged the numbers a little bit with
them really do you see from different
gamma
there's only X on the same side no stop
it okay I just subtracted one in six
eight from both sides do great that's
what she's not from here to here that's
how I could quickly check if this was
indeed this right so in fact you can do
anything to this line you can multiply
it by two you could take the square root
you could add numbers in or you can
divide by anything you like and you'll
get something which how do you say in
solution for example let's just make one
up now can you take us to me and you
help me multiply everything by two by
two x equals what would I get going on
inside
coming up minus 3a okay you go to a mix
oh my god you go to improper so here let
me just write it like this minus 1 and
7/8 times 2 you see I multiply the
left-hand side by 2 and the right-hand
side by 2 so everything is still
balanced what 7 8 times 2 let's just do
it that guy 7 8 times 2 can you do 7 8
times 2 at 7:04 isn't it 7 over 4 yes
what about the one I have what happens
with that guy okay that's just going to
be some soup that's each of it so if
you've got two and this that's a bit
weird too and this we would write it
over like that that's confusing so 26 up
distraction
how much is going to be a whole part
that I can take out there's going to be
4/4 that I can take out of that do you
agree with that
ok the same
so therefore this is minus three and
three quarters so there's another
equation that worked in fact there's an
infinite number equations that you could
write that all have this solution I
could keep on moving around I could move
it all to the right-hand side that would
be another one you need to do news we're
gonna have to bring back a question like
this next time